[音楽]
[拍手]
pane
ana
rear
[拍手]
pou dou dou
th
c
ああああああ
いいした
数社目ますうん
突然なんですけど
皆さんあなたは何者ですかっていう風に聞かれて
どうございましたん
まあを聞かれると思う
ないが例えば
会社員でずーっとか
ん大学生するところ
たぶんそういう答えだと思うんですけどでそれ全然
自然なことじゃないん
と同時に
皆さんの可能性をアルミ狭めてしまっている
今気がするんです
最近の僕うすらしちゃうという言葉を知ったんですよ
調べてみたらすらしちゃっ
複数の肩書きを持つ方のことを言うらしいんですよね
で
その何し合っていうかというとそのまま twitter 垢で
プロフィールに中ではモデル
プログラムが弁護士ライナー3 day
そういうふうにこう職業なんかごスラッシュで組手増やしていくみたいだそういう様
からツアー者ゆえの新しいんですけど
彼らの特徴として1個分やなきゃなくて複数の分野で成功されている
っていうことが挙げられます
ねえ
じゃあそう言うところまでいたんかなあっていう話なんですけどまぁドレーバこう
有名なレオナルドダヴィンチ3まあ芸術家としてもらいぞう抱えたこと言うんです
けれども
例えば思想家であるとかあぁこう学者発明家みたいな大
おっしゃいました
まあそういうふうにいらっしゃるにもかかわらずじゃぁ日本でそういうことってよく
あるのかなっていうと
まだまだ j 著している概念じゃないと思うんですよね
添えてすごい問題になりなと思います
3ガンまあ人のことを引き合いに出したんですけどじゃあお前はどうなんかという話
ですけど僕がもしいないほどしか聞かれたら
僕もスラッシャーですとか
僕がはシーンですけども言いたいなん
a
いろんな事やっててその中でも一番挙げるとすればまあ縦断者かなというふうに思って
います
でもそのまあ自分にダンサーとしてじゃあめちゃくちゃ成功してるんかって言ったら
真っ正直そうじゃないですか
多分皆さんを与えてくれ知らないと思うということ
いったもの一般的には僕は彼らの大学生なんですよ
餌やわかっているんです心の中でああ
でも
自分で自分にそういうふうに大学生っていう1号さんいただけないんですよ
っていうところが自分の昌子源気持ちです
まあ先ほど観ていただいたの通り
まあ僕は段差でスティーブに事後共演させてもらったんですけど
具体的にどういうことをやっているかと言うと
hiro もちろんまだよく行きますよね
夜は科部長のショーパブでアップダンサーとして働かせてもらっています
なんか故障パブダンサーというとは何か怪しそうね
まあそういう印象も大方も多いかと思いますあまり縁のない職業だと思うんですけど
まあ自分自身やっぱりそのオファーをいただいた時によれば世界に入る事に対し
まったくわからなかったわけではないんです
でもそのまま auto まあテーマにも
だしたように自分の座右の銘はやらない後悔よりやる後悔
いうところなんでそれにそーくわけにはいかないなというところがあってパーを決して
カー攻略しございました
女
ああそこで終われば良かったですけど自分で者 by なんで
与えりゃクマリ上ことをしたいと思うんですよ
えっ
その断念某謎の生活をする方がら小学全体の経営についても考えるだったんですよね
で実際そうな業界に入ってみたらわかるんですけど小かぶってお客様と
後まだん33店舗があって成り立つものじゃないんですよ
やっぱりその他にもお酒を導入してくれるまあ&リング業者の方で後か
近隣の公共某た車小板な形であるとかそういった
いろんなステークホルダーがあってはじめてショーパブっていう日ですが成立するん
ですよね
でそれで全員同じ方向も入れたらいいんですけど
みんな望ん力は違うわけですよ
例えばへ面倒煌両側からすればなるべく省の回数を増やしてチケットの売り上げを
伸ばしたいというふうに思います
逆にドリンクを納入する側からすればなるべく
ショートショーの間のキャストとお客様の恒例の時間を増やして
バーカウンター稼働率を上げたいっていうふうに思ってんですよね
ああそういうその他来まーすいくフォルダーの意向をいかに汲み取って全体の利益を
同様に最大化していくかっていうところ
考え続ける日々でした
でまぁそういう興亜た訳まりジョン後藤は
やろうとするみたいな姿勢はまぁ後でお話しするんですけど
まあ自分もその企業みたいなそういう他のプロジェクトの場面でもすごく役立ったなっ
ていうふうに思っています
そういう高与え何百枚ということをやってしかも既存はチャンスは迷わず掴むっていう
そういう姿勢は僕にテレビ出演9回も与えてくれました
自分は元々あの塾講師のアルバイトをしてたんですけどその時にあ文豪皆さんも経験
あると思うけどなあんせんじゃすき家
ガンバロン事業は海水シーデーピージャパン先生なんかなんか
左ちょっな通行なんか相性みたいなんであったと思うんですよ
自分が教える際もあってもそれをすごく感じるところがあって
やっぱり人と人の相性ってやっぱり大事なんだろうなっていうのが漠然として気づきと
してあったんですよ
でもそこで全然分析茶どころじゃないかってあかんなる気づきにとどまったんですよね
でまぁどっちが流れて
友人に誘われて
まさに県内のそのビッグデータ星ですね
に関する経済番組に観覧として選んでもらう機会があったんですよね
でその時に
92その番組のホストの方が観覧席に向かって今中で新しいレースを持ち出している
ミネ子と急に問いかけてくれたんですよ
姉あがマジ分咲き運転で地面ってあこれチャンス選んだよ
と思ってでまぁ元々思ってた子服を主としてそのまま相性大切だ
の問題と
あとはそのままビッグデータ基本的にまあいろんなデータを集めて分析してサイズ気が
するって言う手法じゃないですか
だからなんかこそこでマッチングみたいなものも最適化できるんじゃないかなという
仮説を持ったんですよね
猫のを路へ9回ドイツのよりの支援
で思い切っててあげましたそんなに入っ
デマーコ元々持ってたそういう気づきと
後は外に思い聞いた勇気のおかげで岡山その番組にその後も1か月ぐらい
継続的に出演させていただけることになりました
でここまでだとまあ自分がうまくいった感じだっ会でお前
自慢しに来たんだ
続あると思うんですよ安いよね本当に
ん
んですけどまぁこんないいところからじゃないですかこういう番手やさ
この何倍も失敗していいですよ僕は
でそんな中でも自分が一番文はだったなという印象に残っている失敗はそのは会社を
立ち上げた時の事なんですよね
ねえその自分大学2年生の時に深夜総武家もなんか教育をテーマとしたメディアを運営
する会社をやってたんですよ
デイ
立ち上げまでは比較的スムーズに行ったんですよじゃあこのまま行けちゃいなんだよ
だけごらん完璧に考えていました
でもその収益化のポイントが曖昧のまま走りだしちゃったせいで
ほどなくして運転資金は底をつき
会社倒産の危機に陥りました
でこれやばいなんだよななんかこう
応援してくれたとすること家族とかですがこの借金やばいっていう社会でいう間に借金
やのお前は行ってみたいなことで結構否定的な論調を惹かれなんてアーマーここまでか
なっていうふうに半ば諦めかけたんですよね
でもまぁ自分諦めが悪いんですよ
ブーブー言うもうしない度胸
表現力担うのは多少身についているかもしれんと思ってそういうのは堅苦しいばじゃ
なくむしろ頭の歯のほうが効果的なんちゃうかなって思って
そっから必死にバイトして貯めたお金で企業の締めプーさんが集まる
合計のバードで居酒屋に足引っ張られました
bouvet にいらっしゃる方に自分へ話ですけど
まーぬーやり続けたんですよエアーロサンゼルスた
でもやっぱり今何か面白がってくれてみたいですよね
なんかこいつ必死やん君音を立てで
で a それは3カ月で続けたんですよ
そしたら都内で教育関連の会社をやっている方がおもろいやん
猫事業内容に信用性を感じてくださったみたいでー
秋がリズムんで一月号してもらえるだったんですよね
ねえっ
まあそのそこからエイター千船の学びというか
それは失敗を失敗のままで終わらせ粘り強さんけ
ところかなと思うんでええ
そのやっぱり物事がうまくいったがいかなかったがあって法令上つでがないっていう
ところまであらゆる手段を講じて初めて判断できるって言うの自分を持っています
a もちろんその例えば測器っていう考え方とか
あのまただけ上がるだけあるとかいろいろそれに対しな意見はあると思います
これが全体でみんならしい考え方だとは思ってないんですけどでも自分なりの行動指針
を持つっていうことは大事なんじゃないかなというふうに僕は思います
day まあここまで結構いろいろ成功探し失敗探し
どちらも聞いていただいたんですけど共通して思うのはやっぱりの勇気を持ってあなた
耳が遠い言語とができれば自分で自分の可能性を広げていけるっていう事だと思うん
です
でここで言うあなたの深海っていうのは自分が風になっているぞ
本当に塗装されればガンペリーとかなんかわかんないけどそういう骨誓っていた
ものが一切来ない世界にあえて自分の身を置くことで
自分の定義を上書きしてスラッシュを増やしていけるっていうふうに僕は思います
a
なんかこう小さな選択の数々って匹見
訪れると思うんですよでいきなり大それたことができなくてもそういう小さな戦略に
入って受け入れてぃ
チャレンジしていくうちにいつしか自分がそうともしなかったな刺激できる
思いますねそういった古いの世界で始めること
と同じくらい難しい続けること妻に感謝僕は一定の責任を持つ大
いうふうに思っています
やっぱりもうそこって不利な世界ながらこそ難しいところと思うんです
だからこそ皆さんにはそういった後ちーさん選択に家して答える
勇気を持って星で自分には無理や奥田そういう言葉で自分に1000匹をしないで
ほしいですよね
最後に行か遊んいい池やてぃていただきたいんですけどちょここまで1試合パティあっ
やってるよえっこりゃっ
追ってくれたけどにょでしょっ
ここにいる方の中で半分がそう思ってくれたと集じゃないですか
帰宅する時までその気持ちいいしていて多分その半分ですよ
で次の日の朝起きてもそれを持ってのサイズも半分なんですよ
で実際実行に移す人ってそんだけの1割にも満たないかもしれないんですよ
っていうぐらい僕の経験からして第5話思うだけなんですよ
でも
だからこそそこでとりあえず行ってくるっていう姿勢を皆さんとシェアしたいですよね
day
岩お前何者でもないくせに偉そうになっどうぞもだけどいないこと言われてたんやねん
こいつあってムカついてくれた人はそんなエネルギーを
こう自分で行動するエネルギーに変えて
これまでとは少し違う人生を歩んでもらえたら僕はすごく嬉しいです
ありがとうございました
ます